what is the best upload schedule for
YouTube yeah so this goes right back to
uh replace it with the audience so what
is the best upload schedule for your
audience and if your audience does care
about when you upload then you should
care about when you upload and that can
be things like breaking news where they
expect you to have timely coverage you
know some channels put up three four
five videos a day of breaking news and
that has a shelf life and so it's very
important to get that up almost
immediately time of day doesn't matter
as much but the timeliness really
matters and then you have channels like
Mark Rober once a month you know Nile
red I think like two or three times a
year maybe and they get Untold millions
of views and it's like sciencey and they
have a very different
expectation so I think like figure out
what of course like figure out what's
best for your own well-being like you
your family everything that's important
to you and then one of the cool things I
tried is I did I did one video two
videos three videos four videos a week
uh for a while and then I did uh videos
published compared to average views per
viewer and I could see where people were
hungry for more and the more videos I
published they started watching more and
then as I got towards four I could see
that they're starting to choose between
them like they were coming to YouTube
and seeing two videos or they're like I
only had time to watch one and that was
like the law of diminishing returns
hidden immediately two things number one
I've had too much coffee today number
two if you have not seen our free master
class yet you're gonna love it if you're
serious about growing your YouTube
channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class